[Music]
on this busy Wednesday night a car
explodes at the Canada US border near
Niagara Falls yo oh my God are they all
right the investigation plus what an
eyewitness says he saw that vehicle
doing before the
blast more breaking news the verdict is
in the former RCMP intelligence director
accused of leaking Secrets learns his
fate hope for families of hostages in
Gaza when the fighting is expected to
pause and who might be released and the
return of the tree that talks we should
all just be kind to one another seasonal
small talk from
Woody global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a fiery vehicle explosion
at the Canada US border crossing near
Niagara Falls on the eve of American
Thanksgiving the Govern governor of New
York State said tonight there is no
indication it was an act of terrorism
this video shows the fiery scene right
after it happened two people inside the
vehicle were killed when it exploded
near a border inspection booth on the
American side of the Border a US border
patrol officer was injured it happened
just afternoon on the Rainbow Bridge
that connects Niagara Falls New York to
Niagara Falls in Canada that border
Point remains closed to traffic right
now three other nearby Bridges
connecting Western New York state with
Canada were also closed but they've
since reopened the FBI quickly moved
into investigate trying to determine who
was in that vehicle and if the crash was
intentional it now appears it was not
Jeff SLE is near the Rainbow Bridge
tonight Jeff help us understand what's
known so
far well Donna the governor of New York
state held a press conference late today
to stress that at this point there are
no signs no indications that this was a
ter terrorist attack residents though on
both sides of the Border were on edge
for several hours today this is the
Rainbow Bridge right behind me take a
look one of the busiest non-commercial
border crossings going into one of the
busiest times of the Year American
Thanksgiving but as you can see it has
been closed since noon local time and US
border officials just released this
surveillance video that as you can see
shows a car traveling at such a high
rate of speed that it hits one of the
Border barriers on the US side and then
flies into the air eventually coming
down crashing into one of those US
border booths and exploding upon impact
the FBI describing it as a vehicle
explosion and Witnesses saying that
parts of that car were incinerated and
spread for dozens of meters have a
listen we were walking up the road and
we seen this car coming down towards the
border and he was flying over 100 miles
an hour there was a car in front of him
he swerved out went in front of the car
hit the fence went flying up into the
air he hit I think there was a elevation
part he went up into the air and we just
seen the Fireball and that's all we
could see it was just covered in Smoke
everywhere so the car was coming from
the US into Canada towards Canada yes it
was going towards Canada
yes now as soon as that news broke today
it sparked speculation that this might
have been a terrorist attack in part
because authorities in New York state
had actually released an intelligence
bulletin this week warning of a growing
life hood that violent extremists may be
planning attacks against the West
including New York state in response to
the ongoing war in Gaza but again at
this point authorities including the
governor of New York State stressing
that they believe that this was a
horrific accident have a listen and
we've been on heightened alert since
October 7th that's why it's so important
for me to stand here and tell the world
based on what we know at this moment and
again anything can change there is no
sign of terrorist activity with respect
to this
crash now the three other International
bridges over the Niagara River have
since been reopened but as we mentioned
Rainbow Bridge remains closed
indefinitely there is still a very large
police presence in this area in fact
police as far away as Toronto two hours
down the highway saying they are
increasing their Patrols in that City
out of an abundance of caution Donna
okay Jeff simple at the Canada US Border
in Niagara s Ontario thanks there is a
verdict in the high-profile case of
Cameron ortis he's a former RCMP
intelligence director charged with
leaking Secrets a jury has found ordis
guilty on all six charges against him
the 51-year-old was accused of using his
position to reveal classified
information back in 2015 ordis had
pleaded not guilty claiming he was
acting to protect Canada from what he
called a grave threat Tria isri is
outside the Ottawa Courthouse where the
verdict was delivered
Donna Cameron ortis was a rising star in
the RCMP he also had access to some of
Canada's most closely guarded Secrets
now the crown had argued he used that
access to make money to sell that
information to police targets and
tonight a jury found him guilty on all
six charges under the security of
Information Act Now ortis was arrested
back in
2019 um this was related to an FBI
investigation which was looking into a
cyber Criminal inant couver who would
sell encrypted cell phones to criminals
now emails that were shown in evidence
in court show that Oris tried to sell
classified information he had um to the
man who ran this company for
$220,000 uh the crown called this case
very tricky given how sensitive the
information was but said that it shows
the system works take a lessen with the
outcome we think what it does is it
signals the importance with which Canada
takes the protection of sensitive
information and that those who don't
respect sensitive information will be
prosecuted now there was a much
different reaction from the defense
lawyer representing ordis he said he is
shocked disappointed and that the jury
is sending an innocent man to jail when
we go back to court in January we're
going to tell the judge that in our
opinion Mr ortis has served enough time
and there's no basis to further
incarcerate him now police took ortis
away handcuffs tonight he is going back
to jail the crown is expected to um ask
for in the range of 20 years and that
sentencing hearing is scheduled sometime
in January Donna okay teria isra in
Ottawa tonight thanks in Israel the
families of hostages are counting the
minutes until what they hope will be the
release of 50 women and children held
captive by Hamas in Gaza for 47 days now
families of more than 200 people taken
by Hamas have been bading for their
release Israel has apparently agreed to
a 4-day pause in fighting to allow at
least 50 of them out in exchange for 150
Palestinians held in Israeli prisons and
for humanitarian Aid to enter Gaza that
was expected to begin at 10:00 a.m.
tomorrow local time but late today
Israel's National Security Council
chairman said the first hostages will
not be released before Friday Israel's
prime minister said the deal includes
the International Red Cross being
allowed to visit and give medical
support to those hostages who will
remain in Gaza though the Red Cross
later said it was not made aware of any
such agreement until the hostage release
actually happens everything is uncertain
Mike Armstrong explains in a warning
some of the images in his story are
distressing this is not a deal made
because the two sides trusted each other
it wouldn't have happened observers say
without
mediators Hamas and Israel believed the
assurances from the intermediaries cter
the the US and
Egypt well whatever it took the families
of the hostages are hoping it holds how
do calderon's teenage daughter
12-year-old son and husband are all
believed to be held by Hamas I just want
to hug my children to kiss them to
protect them to promise them that it
will never happen
again the deal is for 50 women and
children who were taken hostage October
7th exchange Israel will hand over 150
detainees it's holding Wednesday it
released a list of potential names in
fact 300 making it clear it's open to
further exchanges now some on the list
are being held for things like throwing
stones others more serious crimes This
Woman's daughter is serving a 10year
sentence accused of a stabbing attack in
2015 she says she started getting calls
at 5:00 a.m. that her daughter was part
of the deal and she's optimistic she'll
get her back now not everyone is happy
about who could be released an Israeli
victims rights group appealed the deal
to the Supreme Court trying to have it
quashed the appeal was rejected that
should mean the shooting stops but in a
statement Hamas says its Fighters will
keep their fingers on the trigger while
the Israeli Defense Forces say they will
still consider themselves at War an
operational pause for release of
hostages does not change
it well during the temporary pause
Israel has agreed not to monitor Gaza
with drones or aircraft that will not
however give Hamas free reign to move
around it's not the same as a solution
this former National Security adviser to
Benjamin Netanyahu says Israeli forces
will be watching from satellites he says
they'll have an idea of where Hamas
Fighters will be on the
battlefield and expects the IDF if it
can to go after them as soon as the
pause expires I think that we should
prepare everything that it will be
automatic the the fire is ended at 12
:00 12 and 1 minute we are back in the
business The Prisoner exchanges are now
expected to start Friday they'll be done
in batches of 10 hostages for 30
Palestinians children are expected to go
first meaning 70-year-old Judith
Weinstein the Canadian may or may not be
included Donna all right Mike Armstrong
in Jerusalem thanks there is more video
today of what Israel's Army says shows
Hamas tunnels under gaza's largest
hospital team from Reuters News was
taken inside what the Israeli Army
claims is a reinforced tunnel it extends
under elifa hospital and has what the
Army calls an air conditioned Hideout
room and bathroom Global News cannot
independently verify that video the UN
Secretary General says a pause in
fighting if it happens would be an
important step in the right direction
there are hopes more Aid will start
moving into Gaza 2o though as Crystal
ganing explains right now the fighting
is not stopping and a warning some of
the images in her story are
disturbing the labor of the
living to honor the debt they're said to
be victims of the war from Gaza City and
Northern Gaza individuals young and old
unclaimed by loved
ones we couldn't identify these Martyrs
we receive these bodies as you see
them may their souls rest in peace
peace is not easily found in Gaza many
cemeteries are full and no one knows if
they'll have time between strikes to
bury the dead Israel has clearly stated
its goal of eliminating Hamas and did
not ease up Wednesday even as the
negotiated pause in fighting Drew
closer what truce are you talking about
with these massacres taking place is
this called a
truce while those in the middle of the
war have little optimism Aid groups are
banking on the temporary halt in
fighting to help those in desperate need
but four days is is is a Band-Aid on a
huge gaping open wound and it's not
going to allow us to address the scale
of the challenges right now in Gaza it's
being reported that Israel has agreed to
allow 300 Aid trucks to cross at Rafa
during the pause in fighting Danny
glenwright would like to see all
hostages freed and a ceasefire and the
psychological effects of 4 days of a
pause and then to go back to a situation
where bombs are falling on hospitals on
schools on places where people have
taken shelter it's unconscionable while
food water fuel and Medicine may be
coming one thing that is in abundance in
Gaza is suffering Crystal ganing Global
News
London prime minister Justin Trudeau
says he hopes a pause in fighting would
allow more Canadian stuck in Gaza to get
out it's going to allow for protecting
of civilian life including hopefully
getting even more Canadians and and
foreign Nationals out this is an
important bit of progress but we have to
redouble our efforts now to get towards
a uh lasting peace according to foreign
affairs minister Melanie Jolie about 200
Canadians or people connected to Canada
are still stuck in Gaza a tech Titan who
was fired gets rehired coming up the
latest twist in the drama at open
AI the newscast that's more than just
the news of the day just a ton of
explosions happening all around us
covering and uncovering stories that
matter this was the first hurricane
where they truly felt scared this
Chinese fighter jet is within a few
meters of the wing global national with
Donna freezen we are less than a
kilometer away from Gaza winner of the
2023 Canadian green Award for best
national news anchor and best national
newscast if you get global news from
Instagram or Facebook that has changed
due to meta's decision to block Canadian
news in response to new government
legislation easy access to important
breaking news and information in Canada
and about your community is no longer
available on meta platforms go to
globalnews.ca and sign up to get news
alerts delivered directly to you and and
learn about how Bill c18 affects your
access to Canadian
[Music]
news India has begun issuing electronic
visas again for Canadian Nationals two
months after suspending the service in
September the Indian government stopped
offering e Vis visas after prime
minister Justin Trudeau says there is
evidence the Indian government may be
connected to the killing of sick
activist Hardeep sing nider a Canadian
citizen was shot in June outside the
temple he led in Su BC India denied the
allegation calling it absurd and in
Washington allegations of another
assassination plotter making headlines
the financial times and Associated Press
report that us authorities have raised
concerns with New Delhi after thwarting
a plot to assassinate a six separatist
on American soil the intended target
gatan sing panun is a dual American
Canadian Citizen and is a leader of six
for justice which advocates for an
independent six state in India David
Aken has been looking into the
allegations and the reaction on both
sides of the Border David well Donna as
circumstance would have it Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi had convened a
virtual meeting this morning of G20
leaders including prime minister Justin
Trudeau and truda was asked after that
meeting if he brought up the allegations
of this plot I reemphasize how important
it is to abide by the rule of law and to
engage constructively uh with each other
when we have uh issues of concern US
president Joe Biden did not participate
at the meeting but after it was over a
White House spokesperson said the US
expected India to investigate the
allegation it is the administration's
expectation anyone deemed responsible
should be held accountable and that's a
view echoed by Trudeau we have been
working closely with uh our allies
including the Americans uh since uh
since the middle of the summer uh
obviously we continue to uh engage with
India in hopefully constructive ways and
we hope that uh India will continue to
take these real concerns seriously we
are asking this the target of the
alleged plot was said to be gatan Singh
pan India considers panon a terrorist
and his organization six for justice is
outlawed in India panon has organized
events and rallies in Canada and earlier
this year he told Hindu Canadians to go
back to India leave Canada go to India
he is also under investigation by
Canadian authorities for for alleged
threats against Air India panon is a
dual citizen of Canada and the US he did
not respond to interview requests but in
a statement he sent to Global News he
said he would leave it to the US
government to respond to the alleged
threat on his life India's foreign
Ministry for its part said simply that
the allegations raised by the US were
quote a cause for concern for both
countries end quote and that it takes
the matter seriously it's a much more
muted reaction than when Canada accused
India of involvement in the murder of a
sick activist in BC Donna David aen in
Ottawa thanks there is another
surprising twist in the tech World open
AI has announced that Sam ultman is
returning as its CEO the company behind
chat GPT says it reached an agreement in
principle to bring ultman back after he
was abruptly fired on Friday it also
announced changes to its board of
directors alman's surprise firing
sparked a Revolt among open AI hundreds
of employees who threatened to quit
Alman was set to join Microsoft to form
a new AI lab there before his return was
announced ahead new marching orders for
Canada's two newest
astronauts Canada's two most Junior
astronauts are taking on big new
roles Joshua citri is going to the
International Space Station on a
six-month Mission he's expected to
launch an early 2025 and he'll become
the fourth Canadian astronaut to serve a
long duration mission on the space
station Jenny Gibbons has been chosen as
the backup astronaut to fellow Canadian
Jeremy Hansen on the highly anticipated
Artemis 2 lunar mission that is
scheduled to fly around the Moon as
early as November
2024 South Korean pop stars black pink
have been given special honors at
Buckingham Palace that's King Charles
making the K-pop quartet honorary
members of the order of the British
Empire for their commitment to raising
awareness about climate
change everybody say
trees next cute or creepy the Nova
Scotia Christmas tree that's the Talk of
the
[Music]
Town parents all know about taking their
kids to see Santa at the mall it can be
either wildly exciting for them or a
little nerve-wracking
well there is another tradition making a
comeback at a mall in Nova Scotia it's
Woody the talking Christmas tree who is
likely to either charm children or haunt
their dreams Heidi petruk went to meet
him 1 2 three
Tre tree puns just part of the charm
you're on Santa's niess this year of
Woody the talking Christmas tree he's a
great Christmas tree he so jeal and
happy and so excited jingle bells jingle
bells jingle all the way a shopping
center staple that dates back decades
he's not just special to children it's
people of all ages it's people of all
walks of life somebody who visited uh
Woody as a young child in 1983 would
have been back in the 2000s with perhaps
their own young family um and now
perhaps coming back with their
grandchildren back in the 1980s though
this fur didn't look so fresh with a
Visage perhaps more haunting than
holiday I think he had a nice little
face lift
now following a brief reappearance in
the early 2000s Woody took a 15-year
Hiatus got a refresh and reemerged in
20121 and social media transformed The
Towering tree into a
star I get it but it's kind of creepy
it's okay if other people think that
he's creepy
that's okay it doesn't hurt his feelings
creepy or cute Woody is now part of
popular culture with cheeky social media
feeds and on brand swag proceeds going
to the Region's children's hospital but
take away all the trimmings of
modern-day marketing and it's about
something rather old-fashioned at the
end of the day I just think that Woody
appeals to Something Inside every
everybody hi Woody hi Woody it's so
lovely to see you I love making new
friends
The Wonder of the holidays even if it is
a little weird Heidi pic Global News
Dartmouth Nova
Scotia and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna freezen
tonight's your Canada is the great Cup
Parade in Montreal thousands of football
fans celebrating the Montreal aletes
winning the 110th gray cup thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
w